talk to me about the ambush this isn't
the first time you've used lethal force
while wearing a mask the press would be
calling me a hero I work for the federal
government FBI help keep me on the
straight and narrow but now you drowning
in deep water to understand attack to
attacks
I've never seen a talent like yours
we are in danger
he felt someone to kill me
Oh Karen I'm daredevil hey everybody its
charlie we got brand new bullseye
footage to break down just explaining
his backstory and just clarifying what
they're doing with the character and
that he is the original version of
bullseye from the comics but they're
going with the Benjamin Poindexter name
because they're trying to be a little
more real-world with it the bullseye of
the comics just alluded to the name
Benjamin Poindexter but it was never
verified people just assumed that he was
always lying about his true identity
because it's New York Comic Con there's
a new round of that spider-man ps4 game
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video
fun fact bull's eye was actually Hawkeye
during the Dark Reign version of The
Avengers The Dark Avengers in there are
rumors that Marvel just commissioned a
script for Dark Avengers so I'll talk
about that at the end of the video
because well that sounds really badass
there are a couple of other characters
that they have to introduce before they
could do something like that so they're
teasing how this Benjamin Poindexter FBI
agent goes from the straight and narrow
to becoming a villain by the end of the
season how it seems like he's suffering
from some post-traumatic stress that
he's dealing with with a therapist here
where all the tapes are that you later
see him burning like this is probably
once he flies off the deep end like just
burning all of his sessions with the
therapist and finally flying off the
handle and embracing this darkness
within him within the context of the
series they haven't claimed how he came
to be in the FBI if he came from the
military because the original bullseye
of the comics actually was a mercenary
who fought in the military for a brief
period because you imagine how people
got really twisted during the wars that
you saw during the Punishers backstory
imagine whatever mental problems he's
suffering from in this series some of
that may have been caused by time in the
military but you also see flashbacks to
him in the baseball uniform the original
version of bullseye from the comics was
also a baseball pitcher because of his
perfect accuracy he was a total badass
the trailer also lets you know what his
skills are if you're not a big comic
book reader he has perfect aim but he
can also turn almost anything into a
weapon like in the way you've seen
daredevil Bank his Escrima sticks doing
crazy trick shots in previous seasons of
and defenders bullseye can do the same
thing with pretty much any object you
could imagine it doesn't actually have
to be a weapon he can turn things into
weapons so based on the conversation
he's having with the therapist it seems
like this is happening after Wilson
Fisk's convoy gets hit remember he turns
state's evidence and is going to inform
on other criminals in the city and
that's how they put him in the halfway
house so either the people that are
running the hit on this convoy are
working for a rival mob boss or Wilson
Fisk himself set this up to make it look
like other people are coming after him
because while all these explosions are
happening he doesn't seem terribly
concerned like this is no big deal or he
expected this to happen but based on the
way that bull's eye reacts during this
scene it sounds like he's working his
detail and wasn't prepared for that
loses his [ __ ] and kills all the people
that had come after them even after they
surrender like those dudes put their
hands up and say fine we surrender and
he kills them anyway
a couple of them he kills with knife
shots to the throat so not only is he
using deadly force he's being vicious so
he has this edge to him that predates
everything that's happening during
season 1 but he says the FBI has been
keeping him on the straight and narrow
keeping whatever dark side he has in
check so it sounds like something
happened to him in the past that was
really messed up that led him to be this
way so that's why I'm just leaning in a
more Punisher direction like he has some
trauma that he's dealing with it's
either from the war in Afghanistan or
somewhere else or he was abused as a
child I love when he's running on the
river here and he runs past this dude
and just knocks him out of the way like
you can tell they want you to feel like
he's a badass but he's a total [ __ ]
he sounds like he hits this downward
spiral and Wilson Fisk starts to take
advantage of him because you started to
get the Fisk dialogue and he says you
have skills society won't understand and
then you see him wearing the daredevil
costume looking like he just got done
doing something really hard like Wilson
Fisk probably tries to sell him on the
idea of getting rid of the daredevil in
that being a good idea because of the
way that a villain would explain that
like look I can do a better job of
saving the city if we get rid of these
crazy vigilantes so it's not so much
bull's eye wanting to be evil it's him
being seduced by Wilson Fisk and falling
for him and then just embracing the
darkness within him
it'll be interesting to see how they
explain him wearing this bullseye hat
maybe that's just a nickname that
someone gave him in the FBI or in the
military but usually that's the way they
do code names like that like people like
this don't call themselves bullseye
usually they get the name from other
people like kill monger didn't name
himself kill monger he was given that
name because of all his kills while he
was in the military we get more of the
scene from Karen pages newspaper when he
comes after her probably to try to freak
them out obviously Karen page knows that
it's not Matt so we get a slightly
different version of the scene where in
the last trailer it was matt saying who
are you after he recognizes his skills
like wow you're wearing my costume and
you have moves that seem a lot like mine
and he says I'm daredevil but in this
version he says I'm daredevil Karen as
if she's like who the hell are you
you're definitely not Matt Murdock kind
of hard to tell where this church scene
happens during his arc because it
doesn't seem like Pat Murdock is
anywhere in here and obviously this is
Wilson Fisk just wanting to turn the
public against daredevil so what would
do a better job of that than having
daredevil mysteriously attack a bunch of
churchgoers but based on bull's-eyes
mental downward spiral it would be kind
of hard to sell him on something like
this early on so maybe this is a little
bit later
I love the imagery of this picture too
it looks like kingpin is going to
negotiate with other powerful people in
the city or there's some bargaining
arrangement that he's making and he
makes it seem like the devil of Hell's
Kitchen is his own personal bodyguard
pretty much all the scenes you see with
someone in the daredevil costume
fighting people is the bullseye fake
version of daredevil so like this FBI
hallway fight here I don't know if this
is gonna be the quote-unquote hallway
fight of the season but it's probably
just part of the plan of turning the FBI
against daredevil so he pretends to be
daredevil attacking his own co-workers
without them knowing who he really is
love the shot of them charging here
inside the newspaper too they just want
to make it seem like they're relatively
evenly matched like bullseye is every
bit as skilled as daredevil so it's
gonna be the fight of his life
then you see him punch Matt out while
he's in the black costume inside the
convent here and you see Karen Paige
cradle him as if he is dying this is
actually right out of the comics except
the comic book
version was Matt cradling Karen page
right after she had died they're already
a whole bunch of visual comic book
Easter eggs you guys are probably
spotted so they're just gonna continue
to show up throughout the season the
rumor about the Dark Avengers script is
just that Kevin Feige and Marvel Studios
commissioned a script they've done that
for a whole bunch of other movies so it
doesn't necessarily mean that they're
gonna make the movie or even make one
right away but if they do wind up doing
that that might take the place of any
potential Thunderbolts movie and maybe
they would push a Thunderbolts project
to TV series on that Disney streaming
service because even though we could
stand to use a few more they already
have enough villains to do a thunderbolt
series that are in lockup within current
day MCU like the ghost character that we
just met during a man in the wasp she's
a perfect candidate for a thunderbolt
series so just keep that in the back of
your mind if that becomes more real than
I'll do a new video about it but for
right now it just sounds like it's
buried underneath a potential pilot
project that Marvel is working on for
the next 10 years what's gonna happen is
is I just got screeners for the first
half of the season so I'm allowed to do
my non-spoilery review next Friday so
it'll be about a week before that post
no worries click here for my venom post
credits scene video and click here to
watch that longer daredevil season 3
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you